oui mes chers amis bonjour bonjour à
tous et à toutes
merci luc de travail que tu effectues
chalut bien sûr notre président du sénat
gérard bruno bernard savez que c'est un
très grand honneur pour moi d'être
devant vous en ce conseil national comme
président de cette commission nationale
d'investiture un honneur un plaisir
aussi
car nous sommes ici en famille notre
mouvement est une grande famille
chers amis une grande famille dans
laquelle chacun est animé par la volonté
de servir la france et les français
et cette famille aujourd'hui elle est
réunie autour de françois fillon qui
sera aujourd'hui officiellement investi
pour être notre candidat à la présidence
de la république
nous sommes désormais tous engagés pour
faire gagner nos idées au moins de
mettre au chant évidemment rien n'est
encore joué
c'est une campagne rude qui s'ouvre en
ce début d'année une campagne dans
laquelle nos adversaires ne nous
épargnerons aucun coût ni aucune
outrance une campagne exigeante
nous allons convaincre les français un
parent partout dans notre pays au mois
de novembre
la primaire nous a laissé entrevoir une
formidable dynamique dans l'ensemble
dans le territoire pour faire de cette
dynamique une réalité dans les urnes
il nous faut désormais jeter toutes nos
forces dans la bataille
et lorsque nous aurons obtenu la
victoire à la présidentielle
ils ne seront simplement qu'on
commencement de cette aventure vous
savez le quinquennat qui vient sera
crucial il sera crucial parce que nous
ne pouvons plus reculer face aux dangers
qui menacent de faire imploser
notre modèle économique et social il
sera crucial
également parce que dans quelques mois
dont quelques mois hollande sera dans
l'obligation de renoncer
à sa succession alors que lui même
disait que tout allait mieux
or vous le savez très bien rien ne va
dans notre pays
nous savons que la france vit un moment
critique que l'alternative c'est où le
délitement où le redressement
il ya quelques semaines vous êtes
exprimés massivement en faveur du projet
de françois fillon
il est le seul le seul à pouvoir
enclencher ce redressement
vous avez été plusieurs millions à
plébisciter ce projet puissant qui a
clairement donné le rythme et le ton à
la campagne présidentielle c'est dire et
faire amie si les attentes sont immenses
c'est dire si la prochaine majorité
n'aura pas le droit à l'erreur ni même à
l'hésitation
c'est dire qu'elle devra faire bloc
autour du futur président de la
république pour accompagner les mesures
qu'il voudra impulsé dès son élection
c'est la raison pour laquelle françois
fillon me nommant président de la
commission nationale d'investitures m'a
demandé de construire une majorité
parlementaire solide capable d'engager
les réformes nécessaires et de les mener
à leur terme
ce principe a été ma feuille de route au
cours de ces semaines de travail pour
préparer ces élections législatives je
tiens à remercier mes collègues j'envoie
un devant moi roger karoutchi alain
marleix qs qui se sont totalement vous
pouvez les applaudir
ils se sont totalement impliqués
avec moi dans cette mission se tient
également à remercier tous nos collègues
de la commission nationale d'investiture
qui ont participé à nos travaux et qui
ont siégé encore hier matin
aujourd'hui nous vous proposons d
investiture qui nous permettront à la
fois de réaliser une large victoire aux
législatives est de commencer le
quinquennat dans les meilleures
conditions
/ amy je vous demande d'accueillir et
d'applaudir françois fillon
[Applaudissements]
en soit nous parlions il ya quelques
instants du travail de la commission
nationale d'investiture qui te permettra
d'avoir une majorité solide permettant
d'engager des tons élections un plan de
réforme
un projet de réforme puissant pour notre
pays mes chers amis nous vous proposons
justement des instituts qui comptent qui
tiennent compte de l'ensemble des
sensibilités qui se sont exprimés à la
primaire de la droite et du centre
un certain nombre de circonscriptions
ont ainsi été réservée pour permettre un
accord global avec le centre nous vous
proposons d investiture qui font monter
une nouvelle génération d'élus puisque
les trois quarts des candidats investis
dans les circonscriptions de reconquête
sont de nouveau candidat nous propose
enfin des investitures qui est
permettront de présenter des femmes
candidates dans 50% des circonscriptions
de reconquête la prochaine majorité
présidentielle sera donc profondément
rajeuni et féminisé
à l'heure où je vous parle la commission
nationale d'investiture a avancé aussi
loin qu'elle le pouvait pour la
préparation des élections législatives
pour poursuivre ce travail dans les
circonscriptions
encore réservé comme pour les cas de
députés qui seraient touchés par
l'interdiction du cumul
le comité politique présidé par gérard
larcher a établi le principe d'une
commission ad-hoc sur proposition de
notre secrétaire général que je remercie
également de son appui et de sa présence
en commission nationale d'investiture je
vous soumets la liste suivante pour la
composition de cette commission qui
rassemblera toutes les sensibilités de
notre mouvement et dans laquelle je
siègerai comme président je vais les
énumérer hadmar l'ex roger karoutchi
gérard larcher bien sûr nadine morano
axel poniatowski bernard acoyer
bruno retailleau christian jacob laurent
wauquiez isabelle le callennec annie
genevard gérald darmanin sébastien
lecornu caroline cayeux luc chatel notre
président jean françois copé dominique
bussereau sophie primas damien abad
véronique louwagie et grégoire de
lasteyrie mes chers amis je vais donc à
présent vous proposer de valider par
vote à la fois les candidats choisis par
la commission nationale d'investiture
pour les élections législatives et la
composition de la commission ad' hoc qui
sera chargé de se prononcer sur les
circonscriptions encore réservé à ce
jour alors reprenez sous l'autorité
bienveillante de notre président votre
petit carton qui est pour
merci à vous merci mes chers amis des
candidats choisis par la commission
nationale d'investiture pour les
élections l'allier battiston nombre
investi et je leur souhaite bon vent
pour cette élection
et donc la combe de la commission ad-hoc
est donc installée elle poursuivra je
peux vous le dire
son travail avec beaucoup de dynamisme
mais aussi il faut bien le dire une
certaine volonté de défendre nos idées
et une majorité très forte françois qui
te permettra je lis tout à l'heure de
transformer de réformer profondément
notre pays nous sommes donc mes chers
amis en ordre de marche partout dans
notre beau pays pour amplifier le
mouvement qui s'est dessinée à la
primaire nous sommes en ordre de marche
pour faire gagner nos candidats dans les
circonscriptions et pour porter françois
fillon à la présidence de la république
[Applaudissements]